تعرضت بعض أكبر العلامات التجارية الفاخرة في
العالم لانتقادات من
مستخدمي وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الصينيين خلال الأيام القليلة الماضية ما
حدث مع بعض العلامات التجارية مثل المدربة
إيفون شاي وفيرساتشي التي تم
استدعاؤها لقمصان معينة لديهم والتي
حددت أماكن مثل ماكاو تايوان و
هونغ كونغ منفصلة تمامًا عن
الصين ، وهذا ليس كيف تنظر إليها الصين
كجزء من سياستها تجاه الصين الواحدة الآن ،
أصبح هذا أمرًا كبيرًا على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الصينية لدرجة أن Coach كان
المصطلح الأول الذي تم البحث عنه في
النسخة الصينية من Twitter المسمى Weibo
الآن نتيجة لهذه الوسائط الاجتماعية الصينية التي
تشير إلى هذه القمصان التي
تبدو وكأنها قمصان فرقة من
مدن مختلفة مدرجة في الخلف ولكن
تحديد ماكاو وهونغ كونغ وتايوان في
بعض الأحيان على أنها منفصلة مقابل شيء
مثل بكين فقدوا في الواقع بعضًا منها
سفراء علامة تجارية مهمون حقًا
في البلاد ، فقد مدرب ليو وين وهو
نموذج سيوبهان شاي فقد جزء جاك ساندي
من فرقة فتى وفقدت فيرساتشي
يانغمي  من هي ممثلة مشهورة ، قاموا
جميعًا بقطع علاقاتهم مع هذه
الشركات بسبب ما قالوا إنها
قمصان غير لائقة الآن ، خرجت كل هذه
العلامات التجارية
تعتذر على الفور تقريبًا عن هذه القمصان قائلة
إنها أزلتها بالفعل أو
أنها كانت كذلك  التصاميم القديمة قالت ديفون شاي
إن العلامة التجارية تحترم دائمًا
سيادة الصين وتلتزم بشدة
بمبدأ الصين الواحدة ، وذهبت دوناتيلا
فيرساتشي نفسها في الواقع إلى حد
النشر على إنستغرام الشخصي الخاص بها قائلة
إنها لم ترغب أبدًا في احترام
عدم احترام السيادة الوطنية للصين
وهذا  هو سبب رغبتها في
الاعتذار شخصيًا عن عدم الدقة هذا وعن
أي ضائقة قد تكون سببت
الآن مدى سرعة تصرف جميع هذه الشركات
ومدى سرعة
اعتذارها وكيف بدا اعتذارها
ملتزمًا بشدة بكيفية إظهار China Bews نفسها
مع هذه الأماكن  أنت لست فقط
الحساسية في هذا الموقف خاصة
مع كل ما يحدث في هونغ كونغ
ولكن أيضًا كيف  من المهم أن السوق الصيني
لهذه العلامات التجارية
المتسوقون الصينيون هم المسؤولون عن ثلث
مبيعات الرفاهية العالمية وفقًا
لتقرير حيث أن شركة الاستشارات Bain التي
ينتج عنها حوالي سبعة مليارات دولار
سنويًا وفقًا
لشركة الاستشارات McKinsey hadass gold CNN London.